[Music]
in solo moon news sullivan submitted by
bathroom etiquette there's a new trend
to we're newlyweds spend their honeymoon
away from each other what you wanted to
do that I did I wanted to do this really
so then I saw that all like what what's
the thought process behind that well for
me I wanted us to start away from each
other and then meet up so like you know
how so we got married and France yeah I
wanted to have like a week or maybe like
three or four days alone before the
wedding and then have the wedding and
then have a honeymoon that's kind of
what I will have the honeymoon right
after so still spend like seven days
apart and then meet back up with you
it'll be seven days it'd be like I don't
know like four days or something like
heading to Paris
and he does his oh okay what's your
thing what's your thing that what you
think
uncle now I don't even remember we're
going to Amsterdam against some big she
sees Casey there too no you said he
wanted to go to Austria so they said no
like he wanted to go there I don't know
where I wanted to go but I kind of want
it like it would be kind of cool to go
around the globe or something and then
meet in Paris and then go somewhere for
our honeymoon but then it was just too
much time and like this wedding was
already stressful enough and I was just
like mad screw this I just have her
honeymoon like normal people know that
what makes sense to me cuz you spend the
honeymoon together this one they're
spending it apart which I'm kind of not
people will understand knew a lot of
people aren't a lot of people are like
what why would you do that yeah I want
to hear the thought process so there are
some people that are saying that it's
because of scheduling like it's just
hard for them to schedule something
together for some reason how's their
marriage gonna work right now you guys
are gonna get divorced
that's it don't call it a honeymoon just
call it a vacation a lot of people are
saying to like don't call it something
that's supposed to be romantic if you're
by yourself because they're calling it
solo moon that's funny
on Instagram there's almost a thousand
five hundred posts hashtag to that and
they're just saying it like so newlyweds
are just IMing to either a vacation
alone or with friends rather than their
partner why that's weird
so there's so that's like a pre bachelor
but it's like a post bachelor party yeah
exactly
it's like those [ __ ] psychopath women
that goes you know what I'm not gonna
wait for a man to get me a ring so I got
myself my own engagement oh it's like
you are a [ __ ] serial killer that's
I'm that independent I don't even need
your ass let me really mean let me
[ __ ] remind you how much I don't
[ __ ] mean yeah but you're still gonna
be my husband and then I'm gonna finger
myself tonight all right with my ring
finger on while the husband painfully
just watches yeah you're enjoying
watching yeah anyway yeah so that's
amusing now I think maybe like the solo
part it's like okay maybe but the fact
that you're taking friends on this thing
I had to me Oh what the [ __ ] so you
don't want to spend it with that person
but you want to yeah that's right weird
because it would make more sense if it
was like I just wanna be on my own for a
second and then but now she's like a
bomb about everybody yeah it's a post
Bachelorette post bachelor party I hate
it
most people really like the honeymoon
you learn French see most people really
like the honeymoon cuz you're on a high
right after you get married and all the
scheduling and the plan that leads up to
the marriage because if you have all the
family and all the guests you finally
get to go yes some US time some real US
time because you're not going through
this whole ceremony and all these
actions it's finally your time but
instead of going yes finally it's us
time we've just kind of split ways I'm
sick of your [ __ ] now it's time to break
yeah that's supposed to be the the
moment of happiness and you're supposed
to be [ __ ] like rabbits throughout
all different
trees and you come back you know for me
though it's like um the wedding and
stuff it was such a high high that by
the time we we got to the honeymoon
I like crashed from all the happiness
and exact and excitement and all that
stuff like I was just so like on top of
the world during the wedding and then
but I tell me that I'm going to sleep
and relax oh you're just like so
low-energy and so like I can't see I'm
like damn I don't know what's wrong with
me but I just feel so like below me
that's where they get the Soliman like
AC I wish you weren't here
relax a lot you could have been more
energized if you're around your girls
girl maybe people maybe people heard
that and know about that and then this
is their solution because it's kind of
like you don't want to be with your
partner and give them that energy right
because it's like you don't mean to but
it's just a crash and then it makes
sense it's like if you're if you're on
any drugs right which is the same
feeling that you're getting the
endorphins that dopamine everything is
on a high and you're crashing because
your body can't take that much happiness
yeah that's what you're supposed to be
happy on your honeymoon you're like why
am I not [ __ ] happy right but is also
it actually made me not like Barcelona
yeah to be honest with you though the
way you got with the way you like to
travel on vacation is very active and
extreme other people too when they go on
honeymoon they're at a beach they're
chilling and they're relaxing after all
this activity you went from here to
let's walk let's travel to see
everything no so because of all that we
were trying to take it slower in
Barcelona and there were days that like
we didn't plan anything actually the
entire time we were there we're just
like let's just get lost in the city and
see where we end up and then we ended up
seeing things that I was like whoa check
that off I wanted to see that but it
wasn't like but that's but that's but
that's what I'm saying though like
you're still trying to do so my people
are not laying on the floor of a tower
street we actually spent like two or
three days where we didn't even leave
our hotel room like you have chimpanzees
Fanning you and you have a kitchen
they're cute cuz I would that way
because that looks like tropical what if
it was like maybe chimpanzees and
overalls like an alternative was like
you did that but you went to you guys
went to Bali instead and you just had
room service in this foot of an ocean
and you were sleeping on a beach that
sounds amazing to me but Casey's not
that type of traveler he can't do that
that would drive him crazy he needs to
he needs to see the sights and sounds
the moon is for you he's so people watch
and like he needs to like do that you
can watch you I know but yeah so I'm
more of like a check things off my
bucket list kind of person and he's more
like let me just sit at this Park and do
nothing but I need to be in a city and
like observe people he can't do beauty
stuff I could lay on a beach until I'm
roasted you gotta go to tulum dude that
was so fun we didn't do [ __ ] we just
laid there and then all these fools come
up and ask you if you want food and
drinks and we just lay there all day
those sort of accent we like charge it
to the room we ain't moving right yes
yeah I won't do that I'm or the
Philippines really bad yeah can is there
right now he's posting all these
beautiful photos ken looks like he's
from the Philippines
just one time it was so hot so much
traffic was it for work though huh it
was yeah but I'm going from there for
two days
yeah see that's different see we didn't
go to the Philippines go up on a beach
getting that [ __ ] dope ass water have
somebody in the boat coconut like this
is she just looking at a chimpanzee
Fanning don't be a little I'm sure she's
what he wants to wear the glasses with
the visor on it already
my [ __ ] Barbara has been selling me
the Philippines Barbara since the day he
cut my hair baby I mean every time I sit
down he goes do you know what you should
go you should go to the Philippines the
sea the sea food is so cheap I over
there I have college friends they come
down and let me tell you something 300
beers all seafood 160 dollars
you know I could open a lot of love he
says he says he feeds his elementary
school classmates because I guess think
I don't know they have like long
connections it was like 160 bucks all
seafood like lobster shrimp clams
whatever a [ __ ] ton of beer it was a
hundred and sixty dollars for twenty
people insanity in same he goes happy
hour fifteen cents of beer oh [ __ ]
insane man why are we going there for a
night we should [ __ ] Phillipines
homie you coming have a million eyelids
and stuff yeah some of them have pirates
what hey but ya hear that you can rent a
whole island well and then there's like
butler service and stuff I hope they got
chimpanzees it might leave them in you
IOC bring your wheelchair [ __ ] water
looks ridiculous man it just looks
insane Oh pick somebody's [ __ ]
launched him in the air like this I want
to ride a scooter with a chimpanzee on
my back in front like kids where's Jess
in all this no she doesn't like scooters
she's gonna be with you guys at the
resort Jenny's gonna be eating coconuts
and is on the back of the ski [ __ ] oh
she [ __ ] flying on this getting on
the water if you would you guys do feel
anyone we wouldn't hear oh that was we
didn't do on her medially after we did
one the year after did you like that oh
you guys went to New York for your
honeymoon
no Europe uh yeah they were just so busy
at the time so for us it was like we
weren't even gonna plan anything and
then we're like yeah this is cool you've
been there wedding was so like yeah I
guess we can have a wedding that's where
they had tyka yeah was yeah that's
pretty cool we saw like I think was it
like eight countries like eight European
countries in like 10 or 14 days well it
feel rushed
no um not really cuz like they since
they have everything planned out and
like a well-oiled machine there's just
less waiting like when you go to the
Colosseum you go inside you or the
Vatican City you go inside like there's
no waiting a lion like
it's by appointment so like usually they
say the Colosseum is a one day thing
Vatican City is a one-day theme but then
we saw the Colosseum and the Vatican
City and I think a third thing like all
because 80% of is just waiting yeah yeah
cuz all of its waiting yeah but then
imagine you get to go to Disneyland and
without even Fast Pass you just walk to
the line because fast but you stopped to
get a ticket and come back right just
imagine going to the front and you get
to go get the hell out the way why do
they have like a VIP tour thing yeah
they already have the prearranged and
every city you go in they have a native
from that place give you the tour so
we're in Germany was a German tourist
person wandering or in like Cooper yeah
yeah they all have different day and so
they can tell you like the importance of
certain monuments yeah that was it
didn't feel rush because you also have
like a couple hours to yourself and like
three hours is pretty good it just kind
of roam and you're like okay well now I
want to see the next Philippines or
Thailand
I'm dad don't go Cambodia - lets go
shout out to [ __ ] Spencer all the way
out in Thailand oh you know Spencer from
Yoko no I don't know him
oh well he's [ __ ] one of the
up-and-coming dudes there he's actually
a huge fan of JK me yeah so he watches
us on his off time to go in between
kicking people's asses oh my god you
should go there and Hamilton yeah well
he sees he's down dude don't beat us up
well you can't beat me I don't want to
touch me you're [ __ ] insane no but he
says ladies remember all the street food
smell like dog
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]